wir haben eine weitere große razzia
heute erlebt in nordrhein-westfalen im
landkreis türen führen wo polizisten
häuser gestürmt haben
spezialeinsatzkommandos in der
islamistenszene wie wir gehört haben und
unser reporter-team specks ist dort
jetzt in düren und kann uns ein bisschen
helfen was es mit dieser aktuellen
großrazzia dort auf sich hat
ja hallo hier aus düren ich stehe eben
vor einer dieser wohnung in denen es
heute morgen diesen großeinsatz der
polizei gab 350 beamte waren insgesamt
im einsatz an fünf wohnungen ja und die
vorwürfe die eben zu diesen ermittlungen
geführt haben die wir schon schwer den
fünf männer im alter von 16 bis 22
jahren die sollen einen terroristischen
akt also ein terroranschlag vorbereitet
haben uns in anlehnung an opa gander
material des und ich glaube wir müssen
jetzt mal ein paar meter zur seite gehen
wäre nämlich angegriffen gerade von ihm
gehe nicht an die tür
wir gehen einmal ganz kurz raus hier aus
dem aktuellen bild glaube wir können
jetzt noch mal
ich glaube hin zu deiner sicherheit
du kannst die situation sicher besser
einschätzen aber
beenden ganz kurz mal diese schalten wir
schauen dass pur in einer guten
situation aufdringlich einer safe in
sicherheit sagt uns einmal gleich was da
gerade los war